je vous ai sélectionné trois vidéos
d'art cas aujourd'hui que j'ai vu sur
twitter sur un stage dans tout ça déjà
la première c'est le sport en couple
quand on est confiné
c'est bien et quand on le fait à la
maison c'est encore mieux regardez ce
lancement ça c'est sébastien folin vidéo
gag 1986 c'est partir d'hier voilà
bon ben voilà ça c'est ça ça fait du
bien d'avoir des nouvelles de patoche et
médailles 8 en or by naim toujours rage
de dents moment là et je vous dis
benhaim elle a perdu 20 ans ont deux
jours ouais ah mais je vous le dire
s'est terminée là benhaim à la une dans
à là dedans en fait médaille mal à une
dent pour le steak et une dent pour le
fromage et le dessert à tous qui steak
qu'elle ne mangera tous les fromages et
desserts à qui a indiqué ce matin là bas
je peux vous dire là quand on va
reprendre touche pas à mon poste on
plateau tu vas voir qu'ils la belle et
elles vont se passer les dentiers imbibé
mais ça va se passer
bon en numéro 2 ont fait un point sur le
pq challenger bien sûr il y en a
d'autres y en a d'autres qui a essayé
fallait pas ce pécule challenge ce qu'il
fait kiffer cacoub et il est comme un au
dessus voilà regarder
[Applaudissements]
voilà une qui sait c'est pour cacoub et
sur mon ami je fais plaisir
le confinement rend au fond le sait
voici un énième pétage de plombs
regardez cette fois ci c'est en cover
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en revanche bravo bravo bravo aux
délires quand on vous dit restez chez
vous faut rester chez vous même votre
poubelle vous pour vous peut être des
petits coups de pression regardez c'est
parti on y va
c'est une tannée ça je connais ça tu
connais ça ça m'est déjà arrivé sa
grosse grosse lan associant brouille
avec la poubelle et tout bon tous les
jours on le dit quand on est confiné en
coupe c'est dangereux
tu peux très vite ne peut plus de
supporter regardez ceci est un message
officiel est très important qu'on le
corps chirurgicale les chercheurs et les
scientifiques
est ce que vous pouvez me accéléré pour
le vaccin parce que je suis pas perçu à
persuader persuadé que le conflit de mal
mais on va durer longtemps
on t'aime comme scrabble de 8 min tit je
crois que c'était mon préféré aller
heureusement il ya des gens qui ont un
jardin pour ce faire débardeur regarder
ça c'est moi aussi c'est aller à une
petite vidéo
[Musique]
je peux le faire asseoir tête de ma mère
si tu peux le faire et pendant le
confinement il ya plein de gens qui vont
se retrouver aussi avec une tête de roof
c'est sûr et certain on essayait de
prendre soin de soi tout ça mais c'est
compliqué moi je préfère vous lire
actuellement je fais trois heures de
muscu par jour je ne fais que sa voix la
muscu dodo boulot voilà donc je peux
vous dire qu as tu as dis attention
ouais ça fait des ça fait des années que
tu es prêt c'est ça le problème
à les regarder 1 il y en a qui peuvent
pas aller chez le coiffeur mais à une
meuf qui a trouvé la solution pour se
faire coiffer regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aref
thello fall
[Applaudissements]
voilà messieurs étaient des petites
vidéos du jour